happy new year Vsauce Michael here and
in honor of 2013 let's discuss 13 things
to begin where to spend all that cash
you picked up over the holidays now
plenty of websites sell cool stuff
United nuclear sells aerogel radioactive
isotopes jet engine schematics and even
marbles doped with uranium math skier
sells these cool non-transitive dice I
actually bought yesterday as does grand
illusions but they also carry explosive
magic tricks optical illusion masks and
a poster of this image what makes that
image so special well it's an example of
the land effect even though it appears
to contain a bunch of different colors
oranges and yellows and greens the
entire image is actually made out of
nothing
but red seriously I've linked the image
down in the description so you can grab
it and investigate it using your
favorite image editor the yellows are
actually light reds or Pink's and the
green is just dull gray red what's going
on is called color constancy your visual
system your eyes and brain calculate the
average illumination conditions of a
scene and then subtract those conditions
so that colors remain relatively
constant this is why a blue object looks
blue whether you're viewing it under the
midday sun or a dark red sunset or
florescent light or incandescent light
it's a very brilliant system but it can
fool us special images like this one
appear to be illuminated with a lot of
red light so your brain actually
subtracts the red and makes assumptions
there are plenty of other examples of
the land effect and other ways our
visual system lies to us but you know
what else is a lie rain drops well at
least that depiction of raindrops
raindrops are not shaped like teardrops
surface tension means that small drops
are spherical but when they combine in
the air and get bigger the pressure of
the air below them as they fall causes
the bottom to flatten which means that
raindrops are shaped less like
tear drops and more like hamburger buns
but how many raindrops have fallen on
land ever it's a fun question and there
are plenty of resources discussing how
many rain drops fall during a typical
storm but throughout all of history
let's go to math forums org for this one
dr. ian calculated quite roughly but
amusingly that given the percentage of
earth usually covered in land and the
amount of rain that typically falls on
earth and the volume of a raindrop the
total number of raindrops that have
fallen on land ever since earth began is
about 16 times 10 to the 28
so earth has had a lot of raindrops but
you know what earth doesn't have a lot
of nice big old chunks of moon rock
material from the moon is incredibly
rare we can only get pieces of the moon
in two ways by visiting it or by finding
chunks of the moon that were blown off a
long time ago and eventually fell to
earth interestingly you can buy
paintings containing traces of moon dust
made by an astronaut I discussed this
with my friends over at a moto style
video link in the description but the
point is you will not be owning a big
old moon rock any time soon
interestingly a surprising number of the
rocks we brought back from the moon have
been stolen or just plain lost
for instance in 2002 in turns fad
Roberts and Tiffany Fowler stole 101
grams of lunar material from the Johnson
Space Center they celebrated by throwing
the rocks onto a bed and I guess the
best way to explain what happened next
would just be to point out that the book
based on this true story is called sex
on the moon or from a different angle
fun this was built using the side view
maker type in a word or name and it will
construct the word using dots which from
another angle say something else
for instance Vsauce can be
vacuum if you prefer dots that represent
people Brandon Martin Anderson's got
just what you need the entire 2010 US
Census on a map with a dot for every
single person the data is specific down
to the size of an individual block it's
really fun to play around with as is the
searchable Calvin and Hobbs I shared
this on tweet sauce a few weeks ago type
in a word and you can find every single
Calvin and Hobbes comic strip that used
that word words or phrases that help you
remember something are called mnemonics
for instance if you want to remember the
exact speed of light in meters per
second in a vacuum just count the number
of letters in each word of this sentence
we guarantee certainty clearly referring
to this light mnemonic or if you're like
me your biggest struggle is spelling the
word diarrhea well don't worry just
remember diarrhea is a really runny heap
of endless amounts we've all seen
illusions like this before
for circles with corners cut out of them
we perceive an actual square resting on
top of circles even though no square is
there now interestingly if you take this
shape and put it on top of text the
letters within the fake square appear
bigger than the rest of the letters this
is because our brain assumes the letters
are closer to us than the rest of the
text
after all the letters are on top of a
square that's on top of circles on top
of text
speaking of size let's take a look at
the scale of our solar system
OMG space dotnet is a website containing
images of the Sun and the planets to
scale not just in size but also distance
if you scroll long enough you will
eventually get to mercury and then Venus
and then earth and so on or just click a
planet's name and have the site take you
there right away
if that sort of thing makes you feel
small and insignificant rush on over and
grab yourself an emergency complement
dot-com the site will keep complimenting
you until you feel better
but if practicing patience is more your
thing
check out chicken on a raft calm geo
sketch is a really fun way to draw you
have this strange folding mechanism that
draws you can individually control the
rate of rotation for each joint to see
how it affects the image but if you'd
rather combine rotation with our solar
system check out gravity click and drag
to place objects of varying size in the
space and watch how they interact so
there you go
that was about 13 things I guess I don't
really know but there's more
I created a playlist of videos that you
should totally see I host the playlist
and you can start it by clicking the
link at the top of this video's
description or this annotation I call it
a Leanback
because you start the playlist and just
lean back and let YouTube do the work so
what are you waiting for go ahead and
click and I will see you over there and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]